the sewers in southern nevada can tell a
lot about what's happening in our
community wastewater is helping unlv
scientists determine what kind of
influenza strains exist exactly where
and eventually this information will
help researchers develop vaccines a
whole lot quicker heather mills explains
so that we can sample the wastewater
it's a dirty job but somebody's got to
do it
unlv research assistant haley baker and
student nabigani are collecting
wastewater
for science it's rather remarkable how
much information can be gathered from a
community without having to test a
single person they're looking for
influenza our
fecal matter pretty much contains a lot
of information about ourselves edwin oh
is an associate professor with unlv
school of medicine he started this
wastewater surveillance program to track
covet the accuracy is spot on he says
this is truly a technology that is
that is really giving us so much more
information than we ever thought was
possible oh and his team have spent
countless hours collecting analyzing
sequencing and sharing their data
working in tandem with the southern
nevada water authority and health
district he says they can get real-time
results within 24 hours with this
wastewater we can also tell
whether the virus is mutating in boulder
city in a slightly different way from
the city of north las vegas instead of
guessing which flu strain might be
headed our way the statistics right now
are something like 40 to 60 percent of
the time the vaccine is
efficient global collaboration could
ultimately mean a more effective vaccine
so what happens here
doesn't stay here
heather mills live local now